all of these things are important to
remember but the most important thing is
that no one say anything about my
pregnancy at the wedding you know what
you can't
expect them to be careful every time
because frankly it's just a different
sensation michael when you come well am
i wrong they say it's not different but
it's a different sensation oh my god
when you use
something to block
yeah i think everybody knows what i am
talking about it's not necessarily
different for the woman but it is
different okay okay okay michael for the
stop all right
my point is
i said what i wanted to say and mima i
hope you heard every word
[Music]
you call that a robot
try being more robotic okay
because i feel like a banana split
up
[Music]
i was dancing and i did a split and i
landed on my car keys in my pocket
what i tore my scrotum i need you to
take me to the hospital
hey my aunt told me something neat yeah
she said everything with the wedding
goes by so fast we should try to take
mental pictures of the high points oh
wow that's cool i knew when we were
getting married and i'm five months
pregnant that i'm not gonna be able to
wear the dress that i always wanted or
high heels
hey
you look just as i imagine you
bam you're so pretty
yeah
thank you
and who cares
it's a stupid veil right
no this is the one thing i was supposed
to be able to control was this
veil
there
now we're even
good morning how can i help you i left a
pair of dress shoes and a bag outside my
door last night to be cleaned and
polished but they haven't been returned
yet
you must be mr malone one moment please
thank you
mr malone your shoes are gone
they were stolen
no destroyed
what when the bag was opened by our shoe
shine the smell overcame him i too
smelled them and made the choice that
they must be thrown away
incinerated actually but that was my
only pair of shoes it became a safety
issue sir
well
damn it
i can offer you a complimentary
breakfast
okay
what an awesome party the best wedding
i've ever been to i got six numbers
one more would have been a complete
telephone number
this was epic
my kleenex shoes were a huge
conversation piece but man my dogs are
barking
my feet were so sweaty i can't even
build a coal
oh here we go they asked for cash but
you know i give them cash every week so
how much cash does a person need
i have uh taken it upon myself to do
something a little more special i have
painted a portrait of the two of them
from memory
and i have another one of them in the
nude
but that one is for me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one two three four
i beg them that too
i know you specifically put this song on
your do not play list yes i did i'm
sorry
[Applause]
go ahead i think it's your turn
wait what happened you're okay with this
yeah i'm okay
okay
[Music]
did you see this it was on youtube
[Music]
feel the melody
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
breaking
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you